well here's an interesting fact I had to
redo this vlog because in the first tape
I had a fan burger that's right that's
it it was a [ __ ] booger the size of
Jupiter just looking at me like it hello
Oh what is going on YouTube now there's
been something on my mind I have to
express and whether you really like that
you do this or not it must be done now
recently I found out something about
myself
I'm not red yes lo and behold on America
I want to thank you for telling me
because before you said it
I had no [ __ ] clue and in fact it
makes perfect sense because for the past
six years every time I wanted to one of
those you know Black Panther minis a
button to be funny bra my brother
yeah little boy love someone it's one of
the most common things to hear from an
ignorant [ __ ] that if you speak with a
little bit of slang that's suddenly you
have an identity crisis that suddenly I
can't tell if I'm Jackie Chan or Jackie
Robinson so let me just break this down
for some of y'all you need to shut the
[ __ ] so let me explain something to you
the way that I speak does not correlate
to me having an identity crisis it is a
direct representation of where I grew up
and who I grew up around win so let me
just give you an example of what I'm
trying to say so let's say I didn't grow
up in the south side of Sacramento and I
grew up in Great Britain so because I
grew up in Britain now I have a British
accent so what a [ __ ] for all the people
coming up to me saying you're not from
Britain you dirty another problem saying
that you speak with a little bit of
slate that you're trying to sound black
you're basically saying the speaking
improper English is tied to the
african-american community
that's [ __ ] effective how many times
have you ran for that one dude that will
mean one black guy in and all of a
sudden he gave you speech impediment hey
man how you doing I'm Trevor what's your
difficult economy article but you call
me Gucci you need to stop you know every
time you meet one of these fools
sometimes you just want to [ __ ] with
them you ever just make them slave words
on the spot to see if he acts like he
knows what you're talking about you have
a greased ass a mistake
or the hambone car and when they don't
understand what you just said they just
repeat what you said ten times louder
grace a mistake on our hambo no did you
possibly because you know we're not
coming up yeah that's what people say
when they get caught and they don't know
what the [ __ ] sake you suddenly
gaining a speech impediment is not gonna
get you accepted into another ethnic
group what the [ __ ] are you thinking and
also on the flip side of that just
because somebody doesn't sound like the
way you think that they should sound
doesn't mean they're trying to be
something that they're not and honestly
what's happening is this stupid vicious
cycle of hate there's like this
interracial stereotype then people
expect you to adhere to and what I mean
by that is if you don't sound like the
way your quote/unquote ethnic group
sounds like they're people within that
group that I make fun of you for it for
example if you're a black male and you
don't speak with slang suddenly
everybody has to call you a white boy
y'all need to chill out and just let
people be themselves and if you don't
speak away somebody else does don't
change the way that you talk that's just
you do yo boo boo and I bring this up
too because I'll be straight up with you
when I was younger I used to do this
[ __ ] too and in fact it got to the point
where I'll chill them with a group of
Africans and I try to be asking as [ __ ]
oh hello how are you doing my name is
Dee Gilman and a my name is a David
Mundy [ __ ] Oh what is going on you two
get has been a while since I did a vlog
but I came back with this vlog because I
missed y'all so you guys already know
the gear that I'm confident I'm rocking
right now is go for broke apparel and
guess what we are going to go through a
huge line revamp soon so check that out
in a bit my friends thank you for the
support and I love you guys very much ah
so if you guys haven't noticed I miss
funny fat feet a couple times in the
reason why is because I am working on a
short right now we're on the third
revamp of the script so yeah I'm a bit
[ __ ] tired right now doesn't mean
that I'm not keeping up the funny fat
fitness it just means that I don't have
too much time to do those videos because
the short film is my main project that
I'm focusing on and guess what it's
gonna [ __ ] on everybody I'll stuff oh
but thank you guys for tuning in but yes
videos will be back Wednesday and Sunday
because you know I've been laughing on
it but I'll be back
guys I'll see y'all there bazooka go for
broke apparel calm copy gear oh I didn't
visit the last time did it again play
Thor's Shh
oppa boxers not wear pants it's one of
the most common things I hear from the
ignorant funk that if you funk wearing a
bang bong Bing bong bong Bing and Bing
bong Bing it's one of the most common
things I hear from an ignorant funk funk
I keep on saying fun Oh get it to me
papa